بدوره قال رئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلادهم مستمره في بذل الجهود المكثفه
لابقاء قنوات التواصل مفتوحه بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا بهدف وقف الحرب واكد اردوغان
استمرار مساعي انقره لاعاده احياء اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب
كما اقول على الدوام فانه لا يوجد منتصر
في الحرب ولا مهزوم في السلام وعلى اساس
هذا المفهوم نحن محافظون على قناعتنا بشان
ضروره انهاء هذه الحرب المستمره منذ ما
يقارب العامين بسلام عادل ودائم ونبذل
الجهود المكثفه لضمان الابقاء على قنوات
التواصل مفتوحه بهدف وقف اراقه الدماء
خلال هذه الحرب وتهيئه الاطراف للعوده الى
طاوله الحوار على الاقل مستمرون بمساعينا
بهدف اعاده احياء اتفاقيه الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود